Korean Hot Dogs worst worst hot dog
experience in my life why would you go
to Korea to have a hot dog well because
we were in the stadium watching League
of Legends okay and I thought that a
must that I do I I like to do this
everywhere I like to get a hot dog
everywhere I go yeah I want to you know
it's a it's a staple everywhere you go
in the world I love how that's your
benchmark for food everywhere cuz CU you
know it's just interesting that every
I'm so sorry Koreans every single
country has a different like take on it
sure so I wanted to try it and uh it
looked like a ketchup and mustard on the
sign okay I was like I'll take one of
those uh and I hand it to me and there's
sweet corn on it just sweet corn and
like and then it was like ketchup but if
ketchup was four times sweeter right uh
and some other weird relish and then I I
look at the meat and it's just like
white I was like what the [__] why is my
hot dog white and I confirm looking at
the picture it was meant to look like a
normal hot dog sure I B into it worst
hot dog in my life it was terrible it
like flaked apart it was brittle it fell
apart like like uh
cement on you why is that on me I'm
going to put that on you I got a hot
Stadium because you you got a HG from a
stadium because you were probably end in
a country that doesn't specialize in hot
dogs okay first of all I it doesn't
matter if the country specialize in hot
dogs right I every stadium sells hot
dogs and I like testing each Stadium's
hot dogs okay uh and some countries do
it good UK does not do it good have you
had Japanese Stadium hot dogs before uh
no I still haven't actually I've never
been to a Japanese Stadium they suck I
will be the judge don't even bother they
suck com in Korea [__] brittle ass
hot dog sweet corn sweet corn on a hot
dog in what yeah to be fair that is
whack but like that's wild what was what
was the rest of the stadium menu like it
was like fried chicken it's great is
like what you
should I didn't want fried chicken I had
the fried chicken I had like they have
the Korean like street food which like
they peel the whole potato and I hate oh
the the the spiral potato tornado potato
no it's [__] dumb I don't want give
me French fries you know what the [__]
why do I have to get this comically
large stick no you know what's dumb
buying a hot dog in
Korea because they put [__] sugar on
everything in Korea as well yeah and
they're probably going to do it on the
hot dog which they did they did and also
on the [__] the potato which is
french fries they put sugar on it why
because they do that everywhere I want
salt on it did you go to have you been
to a Korean bakery before no but I
presume they just put sugar dude it is
like eating sugar if it wasn't car form
so incredibly sweet also I got Pringles
one
day I wanted aack oh yeah that's let's
talk about all the Korean things I did
in in Korea Pringles listen I had
Pringles one day right the Korean St I
was craving I was craving some God damn
real crisps right I wanted some [__]
salty ass crisps cuz everything was
[__] sweet in Korea and I was getting
[__] sick of it so I go I go to the
[__]
Pringles I'm pleading to like the
[__] Monopoly man or whoever it is on
the front the Pringle man the guy with
the mustache I'm like please I beg of
thee give me something salty I need to
have some salt in my veins and I I look
at the options I have like sour cream
and onion uh there's cheese something
else and there's there's a hot very hot
it says okay so I get the spicy one I'm
like yeah [__] it it's going to be spicy
yeah I [__] I open it up and I I look
at it it's it's like pink I was like hey
that's weird yeah I eat it it's just
[__] sweet it's not spicy at all you
had one right yeah it was just sweet I
was so pissed off how did they do that
it was it was black the the the the
universal explanation for spicy things
is black packaging also in a country
like Korea where there's a lot of
[__] spicy you expected to be spicy
black and red packaging they had
jalapenos on it Peppers cut in half this
was supposed to be it this supposed to
be spicy supposed to be salty i b into
it it's like a light jalapeno that's
been drenched in Sugar can you can you
look up the packaging I want to see this
packag yeah can you can you type in
Korean Pringles hot flavor or something
maybe maybe hot in Korean means like
sweet
uh no no I mean it's that flavor right
um but it is it is that exact flavor you
know because I've seen that flavor
before in
Pringles
uh yeah I think it is that flavor which
one no it's the black one the black one
is like hot and spicy oh H spicy and I
was like oh thank God I get to finally
have a [__] kick and it's it's sweet
so I was I was getting that was the one
thing that was pissing me off of our
career actually everything was sweet I
had miso soup one day I was like great
that's how you know you're really
clutching at straws in Korea get some
salt in your body I I had I had uh I
ordered a My Boy hasn't had a single
Korean meal in Korea no no I went to a b
and bar restaurant right it was [__]
Godlike it it was amazing it
waser so so good it was literally this
small shot run by one dude he was doing
everything the best uh and had to wait
like 10 minutes to get in but it was
[__] amazing it was so worth it and
it was really like it was just amazing
but on the side he brought miso soup
with it and I was like great I get to
have something salty sure I pick it up I
have a sip it's
sweet I think they put you serious yeah
I think they put sugar or something in
the Miso it was sweet okay that as a
Japanese person I am definitely a fan
this is where I literally I I I I sipped
it and I
went what
like oh thank you so much oh this is oat
milk this
is I just took a sip don't worry it's
okay oh [__] oh no oh god oh Jesus oh
sorry sorry I SC everywhere oh my God
I'm sorry I'm so sorry I'll take one as
well okay so yeah I I was I was just
getting that was the only thing that was
kind of annoying me about Korea is that
you just weren't getting a job with the
food no no I I had I had great food in
Korea generally uh be bar was definitely
the Highlight that but then when you
Tred to redeem yourself with the
previous meal you just got worse yeah
yeah and then like I feel like the best
meals I had in Korea was the stuff that
you was is harder to get like outside of
Korea sure like Korean barbecue is
everywhere you knowen Fried Chicken
everywhere as well uh which there were
plenty of good fried chicken places in
Korea but it's very much a case of hey
if you go to the popular touristy places
it's still you know just because it's
Fried Chicken just because it's Korean
barbecue doesn't mean the quality is
going to suddenly increased just because
you're in career did you have any of
like the street food yeah we did we had
a street food day we had it was pretty
good but it felt like cuz all of the
stores were like the same they were
literally all like just copy pay stores
it just kind of felt like it was like I
don't know that it wasn't like what's
the what's the word you kind of hope it
just like one dude who's like I just
make a sick [__] noodles but it was
more like there's an Oreo truck and
there's 15 of them and then there's the
same truck that sells the exact same
meat and it's all the same it kind of
felt like a little more corporate I
think kind of like it wasn't there were
there were some individual stores and
there was one that did like some black
bean noodles that are pretty good yeah
that's really nice I think I think from
from my experience of going to like a
lot of like street food stuff in Korea
like the the biggest like selling point
of it is not necessarily like this store
specializes in this or this store
specializes in this it's like you just
pick a place that you can kind of vibe
with the owner of that store with just
kind of like sit down and just chill
with the dude while having a nice meal I
think that's like the biggest thing it's
not like Japan where it's like if you
want the Takaki you got to go to this
place if you want the [__] okom Yaki
you got to go to this place it's like
just I think like you know cuz unlike
Japan uh I feel Koreans in general are a
lot more just like open to like stranger
friendliness yeah yeah like to yeah
Korean people were so so [__] cool
yeah so friendly especially on this trip
I definitely not started noticing the
difference more between Japanese culture
and Korean culture uh let's I don't know
how I didn't notice this the first time
but holy [__] drivers are
crazy they are insane I I'd forgotten
because I thought tax drivers were
sometimes you'd find an insane taxi
driver inpan I was like the worst the
most insane taxi driver in Japan is the
most sane taxi driver in Korea every
single taxi is like this oh yeah dude oh
my God but you know I I I I've been
complaining a lot about the the
sweetness of the food but it was really
really fun and I I I really like ker a
lot uh I definitely want to go back and
I I got that feeling again of being
completely useless in a country cuz I
don't speak any Korean and I was like a
[__] dud you know annoying part because
I didn't know any Korean I always
defaulted to
Japanese and it was like [__] muscle
memory I kept saying hi and da boot
everything even though I was just like
wait [__] yeah I I would say hi a lot
had to catch myself [__] yeah sees an
Asian and says hi I'm like [__] am I
being racist right now I'm like I swear
to God I swear I'm not mistaking you for
Japanese I this is just muscle memory
right now that that's going on I I felt
like bad that I I couldn't speak much
Korean I was like man I feel like I
should I should be better but also it's
like I was only there for a weekend yeah
we were only there for a weekend and I
like I I you know I I learned the word
for yes and that was pretty much it like
you button I was like thank you thank
you just need a
sound no massive L um really except in
our hotel we had bedet oh yeah it was
like 50/50 for me some bars had bed no
way and some bars didn't they're getting
it they're getting there slowly I
appreciate it I prefer some Bay to no B
days so yeah I think if I I definitely
want to go back maybe like next year CU
it's just so godamn close like a 2H hour
flight one thing that caught me off
guard and this is cuz I've just been a
Japan too long is that people would just
randomly spit occasionally yeah and like
obviously people spit in Japan but you
you just don't see it at all um so yeah
could you imagine fun fact nobody spits
in
Japan yeah it was just really weird it
was super jarring cuz you're like you
know you Japan and Korea they they they
have a lot of similar uh Vibes at times
and then the dude just goes and you're
like oh wow okay wow yeah this is
different yeah they have a lot of
similarities to Japan but then you also
figure out Korea is right next to China
so they take a lot of their like
cultural like I guess uniquenesses from
China as well cuz like I I mean I've
never been to China but I've heard from
people who live in China and friends
from China that like I've been to China
a lot of people like just spit in the
streets like if you go on public
transport there uh at least like when I
went to China which was quite a long
time ago now uh but they you know you go
on a bus or you're going on a plane or
something and people will literally have
spit bags yeah I've seen these
yeah and that's just a bit like too much
of a level for me to be like comfortable
with but the K are like that's a little
too much we'll just do it on the road
yeah yeah yeah uh but but like uh it was
really nice they had a lot of cool craft
beer places that's what I normally go to
when I'm yeah like to me I think like
okay comparing like Japan to Korea I
think Japan H as a whole the quality of
like food is like you know higher in
Japan in my opinion in my personal
opinion if you go to a random restaurant
it's probably going to be always slaps
you know if you go to Korea you there
are plenty of amazing [__]
restaurants there but there can be some
mid places as well that you stumble
into but drinking and the drinking
culture in Korea I think is way more fun
and oh it's next level yeah yeah yeah
that's that's that's what Ker the
advantage I wonder if there CU this is
something I struggled with when I was
there I was thinking like man I I know
where to go in Japan to get all the the
things I like and all the good food and
I and I know what to look for and I I it
was kind of like starting from zero
where I was like I don't know what to
look for and I'm sure that I would
probably say the opposite if IID lived
in Korea for a long time and came to
Japan i' be like yeah but I just think
Korea is more consistent because Japan
you can have some really [__] food um
there's a lot of you know if you go to
uh I wouldn't necessarily say [__] but
like definitely underwhelming you can
get yeah if you just go to really bad
ezekiah a lot you can get some really
like pretty pretty awful food and I feel
like I don't know I I feel like it's
hard for me to properly figure out how
it would be and judge the two I don't
know cuz I remember when I visited Japan
this before we moved here I like every
meal life I thought was [__] 10
banger but was that because was that
because your perspective of Japan at the
time was kind of like oh there's no
place in Japan that can miss you might
you might have had you might have been
looking at the country and the culture
through these Ro tinted glasses and
being like Oh well I mean people will
say this is mid but I think it's
fantastic kind of thing you cuz there's
a lot of people who do that okay you
know you know how you know how I know
you know how I know this is this is the
real test sure you do the Comin test all
right Japan comanies solos Korean
comanies likey oh that's true easy easy
you know and you know I feel like for
the most basic food I feel like you know
basic comedy food I feel like some of
that quality translates into the
restaurants that you get as well I'm
trying to look at this as unbiased as I
can but I you know what do you want to
say Conor no no no go ahead I I'm put my
hand up to say I'll talk yeah I'm trying
to look at this as unbiased as I can but
my memory for coming to visit Japan was
I was never disappointed you know even
if like the only thing that has changed
is my perception of what the top tier
food is in Japan I actually liked food
less when I was a tourist here I I
didn't like food much when I was
visiting here the first time really yeah
I I I I think it's cuz my diet was so
[__] British that I think it was like
it was it was a shock to it's too
Oriental for me I think gen genuinely
like and like it's [__] stupid but
like I I can also now it makes me kind
of like sympathize a bit when people
come to Japan and and I appreciate
they're trying to eat the food but I
know they're not vibing with it sure cuz
sometimes it just takes a little bit of
like exposure to it takes a little while
for you to get used to it yeah like I
remember that I always I always always
really really wanted to like sushi and I
just I just pretended every single time
I remember you told us like you know
when you were growing up in Wales like
rice was seen as like a a luxury or like
a delicacy right it was not a luxury but
more of like a a kind of rice yeah it's
like oh wow rice okay I'm a curry and if
it if if it it wasn't for like Indian
curry I don't think I'd ever eat rice
right um just just not in the like Diet
but I remember the first time I had
sushi I I really really really wanted to
like sushi cuz I felt like I was kind of
a weave I was like I want like I I would
eat I would eat all these cuts of sushi
and I remember thinking like yeah it's
okay yeah it's fine so the first few
times I had it I was like man I just
don't really Vibe with sushi but then
after living here after like a year I
would just start getting these cravings
for sushi and I was like oh I guess I
just I [__] with this thing now right
but I think that's just cuz I've CU
you're climatized to it now right yeah
and I think my my taste pods are slowly
changing and I'm getting older but also
I'm getting more used to the food here I
think it just it just takes a while
sometimes you to like swap oh totally
there are some egregious cases where
people just it pisses me off when no one
tries like if you don't try to eat
anything but I can understand when
people have kind of a hard time getting
used to trying new foods it C I mean
there is a thing called AC quied taste
you know like you have to get your body
kind of used to this like new
Sensational taste or whatever it is
right yeah I just ate a lot of heavier
food so I remember when I was here the
first week or so I was like man I just
want something that is [__] heavy I
want something that gives me the sweat
yeah cuz everything everything was very
light and I was like man I just having
that heavy feeling and now I'm kind of
I've swapped now I'm kind of in the the
Japan Camp of food I'm like I actually
don't want to feel heavy most of the
time but it's just weird how my how that
changes and I guess it's just something
we don't consider when we're talking
about Foods because we always at each
other's throats about crusts and whatnot
but yeah I mean like I I think one of
the big reasons I really like you know
Korean food in general and one of the
things that I got when I in this career
trip compared to Japanese food is that
they know how to do spicy food and some
of my favorite meals when on this trip
was when some spice was involved because
my cheeks were hurting holy [__] I had
like I I remember we when me and Sydney
went to this place I think it was like a
duck gby Place uh where they B basically
awful for your diet probably just like
spicy chicken and then you had like a
bunch of Che melted cheese on the side
and uh you you know you have the chicken
and then you can like plop it on the
cheese and it's like [__] Godlike it
was in like a c iron like Skillet as
well that's the [__] they that's how you
know and that's that's where that's you
get the meat and the cheese sweats from
that and then after you eat enough the
chicken they pour like some fried rice
on it and then they put like put a bunch
of spicy sauce so good yeah yeah then
and then they kind of like fry the rice
on the SK and then they put a bunch of
cheese on the rice put the rice on the
cheese so that you just put a spoonful
in and you get like some spicy rice
fried rice chicken and cheese it's like
a ricey lasagna and oh my God uh I was I
was on the toilet for a full day but it
was so worth it it was so godamn some
bag of cheese duck HBY places in Japan
as like in in um in yeah oh my God also
another thing that ker has figured out
and I have no idea why this isn't caught
on in the in the stadium right when you
wanted the beer you didn't get it in
like an open uh plastic cup you got a
one lit like soda bottle filled with
beer and then the woman goes how many
cups do you want I was like oh [__] I
mean uh I'll get Die four yeah so we
could all just pour each other beers and
then just close the lid that's super
smart I was like wait this is genius why
have we not why is the rest of the world
not doing this maybe because it creates
more waste uh possibly but I don't think
waste is a concern of stadiums I think I
I feel like maybe they just sell more
beer if it's a if they everyone has to
drink I don't know or maybe it's because
like you know because Korea is such a
heavy drinking culture right like they
probably just think to themselves like
oh one cup is not going to be enough if
I'm going to carry like four cups myself
I'd rather just get a full leader bottle
right well was nice cuz we all didn't
have to like go and carry drinks like
one of us could just go get like two
bottles and we could all just share yeah
that's probably what it yeah I mean that
was I guess avoid the cues probably